I finally figured out that I'm not
trying to completely convince you
everything I'm saying I'm trying to
convince you that I believe what I'm
saying so I think there's a subtle
difference when you're influencing
people I have to convince you to believe
everything I'm saying I don't believe
that's true I think I have to convince
you that I believe what I'm saying
that's a totally different level of
influence it looks less like a beggar it
looks far more certain which is level
two level two is the more certain person
will always influence the least certain
person and you know your product so you
should be more certain about it than
they are or your programs all kinds of
things give you certainty number one
preparation knowing your script knowing
your product believing in your product
this is very interesting to me when
people struggle at sales there's only
like certain amount of objections you're
going to get in whatever your industry
is you already know what they're going
to say it's you ought to be ready to
respond to them so most people in sales
are professional presenters they're not
professional closers they're great at
their presentation they can't close and
so I got really good at closing because
someone's going to close somebody either
you're going to close me you shouldn't
or I'm going to close you that you
should you got to believe that I believe
what I'm saying not that you believe
people buy things all the time but they
don't necessarily believe everything
about they believe the person presenting
it to them believes it that's a
different level I used to think I was
really bad at sale sales honestly I
thought I thought sales was
sleazy I thought you're just ripping
people off I thought you're just trying
to convince people to do something that
maybe is in their best interest maybe
he's not but it's definitely in your
best interest I guess I had the
stereotypical view of what a what a
salesperson was I had the negative
experiences from all the people
telemarketing me and calling me and
pretending like they care but they don't
and I really struggle with lack of
authenticity you know I really struggle
with that and every model of a
salesperson that that I would see I felt
like this person doesn't get it I never
want to be this person I never want to
be the the person selling something that
I don't believe in and so I think that
honestly held me back for a number of
years until I realized you you can be
authentic and sell you know you can't
actually love what you're selling know
that it can be valuable to the customer
and move them in a direction that serves
them and helps you too
and I don't know if there's enough
honestly great sales training or sales
examples to to model and learn from
because if you think about your own
experience with sales people most of
them are again just trying to close you
just trying to sell you and it doesn't
feel authentic and it's it feels like a
negative experience it feels it does it
feels slimy
I think back to
when I was 12 and 13 years old and I was
negotiating baseball cards I remember
one kid I had a garage sale and a kid
came up and wanted my Michael Jordan
baseball rookie card upper deck for the
season he played with the Chicago White
Sox and I had it listed for 20 bucks and
he came and he offered me 10 and he said
that that's all he had on him and I said
go home and get the other 10. and he did
he went home and he got the other ten
and why you know why push him well I
believed in the the card was worth 20
bucks you know I believed it was worth
it
not that I bought it for whatever and I
was just trying to make a margin like it
was actually worth it I think to last
week when I was helping Drew Drew's an
entrepreneur invested in he is a
consultant helping other people grow
YouTube channels and I introduced him to
a couple of prospects and I got on the
call with them and helped them close a
couple deals and I have a ton of energy
when I'm talking to somebody about their
YouTube channel that I actually believe
in like if I see somebody who's an
expert like you are an expert you could
be great at this you could be America's
face four whatever you've got a deep
well of knowledge we need to get that
out into the world YouTube has to be
your number one home when I'm when I'm
on a call there's a lot of energy and
excitement
for that because I deeply believe that
it's the best thing for them I actually
see the vision for where they could go
and
it's my belief in them that's greater
than them than their belief in
themselves for this thing that carries a
day
meanwhile there's been tons of things
that I haven't sold
you know the number of people who pitch
me every day with hey Evan can you do a
shout out hey Evan how much does it cost
to promote my product hey Evan can you
be an affiliate for my company
I was like well I have to use your thing
I I've never used your product or
service so I'm not going to recommend it
to people if I haven't used it when I
did a three-year deal with sage
for those OG on the channel you might
remember I did three years of me and
Stephen Kelly who was the CEO of sage
Sage is one of the biggest companies in
Europe
and we did out every month live chat on
my YouTube channel and before doing that
deal with him I loved him he was great
one of my favorite CEOs of all time that
I've met most CEOs are boring afraid to
answer questions afraid to do anything
live he was great but I'd never use I
wasn't a sage user
I wasn't a sage user I was a Microsoft
money user at the time shout out to
Microsoft money and I said in order for
me to do this deal
I need to actually become a user I need
to switch my team over to Sage we have
to be able to use it on a daily basis I
want to be able to tell people and look
them in the eye that I'm actually using
it myself
I want to be able to troubleshoot some
things like if somebody says Hey how do
I look at my balance sheet or income
statement I could point to it and show
it because I'm using it and that was
part of the deal of why we made it three
years is because for me to convert over
and move all my team over was effort
right and it's why I I leave tons of
money on the table because I'm just
unwilling to promote things that I don't
care about or use personally so step
number one is always
I'm gonna use it I'm going to see if I
like it I'm going to see if I can
actually apply it to my business and if
I'm comfortable talking about it or
recommending it then I will and if I
love it then I become such a great
advocate for it I think this is maybe
the missing piece for a lot of a lot of
you who may struggle with sales like if
you actually if you're selling something
you don't like they don't believe in
something that you don't use yourself
something that you wouldn't recommend to
your mom
then don't sell it
people who are just chasing opportunity
think it's a hot time to sell whatever
product don't do you're going to be
you're going to feel gross you're going
to get really poor results you're going
to beat yourself up about it where the
problem is you just don't love the thing
that you're selling I don't think that
there's a lot of value in it where if
you actually do if you love it and you
know that this thing
can solve somebody's problem can have an
impact on their life can can change it
for the better
that's when
you can go all in on it and I think
that's where most people actually
generate a lot of enthusiasm enthusiasm
and excitement I think one of the
biggest challenges for entrepreneurs is
you love what you're doing
you love what you're doing
but you doubt if it's actually going to
work it's your own insecurity about
yourself that you don't know if you're
going to get a result for that person
you don't know if the product or service
is actually going to be the best thing
for them you love delivering you love
creating a product you love helping them
with the service but you don't know if
it's actually going to pay off right you
don't know if if you have what it takes
to actually help them even if you've
helped other people and that's where you
need to get more certainty
certainly in your ability to deliver
certainty in knowing that even if you
don't have everything figured out you
are going to show up for this client
that even if everything goes wrong
you'll find a way to show up
when you can adopt that mentality
everything shifts and changes when I did
my speaking tour and then we had to
cancel on some people because I broke my
neck
said okay we'll make it up to them you
know I'll do I'll over deliver I'll do
I'll do a free call with everybody who
came who paid for that event that we're
gonna that we're gonna cancel on them
we're going to refund them the money
obviously but on top of that we're going
to offer free call with me to help them
with whatever is why did they want to
come to the event in the first place
what's on their mind how can I help and
serve them there's always a way to do
more there's always a way to over
deliver that even if you mess up there's
a way that you can save the relationship
and help and so just keep that in your
mind to help you get the certainty
because
your intention is good you want to serve
you know you're capable of doing it but
there's that little little voice of
doubt that you're not quite sure if it's
going to work out for this client or not
if you can tap into that knowing
that if even everything goes wrong
you can still help them
and you will work your face off until
they are happy
that can give you the confidence to go
in with the enthusiasm and certainly
that's required to actually close the
deal also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
you got to be able to have a big enough
dream that the visions and the dreams of
the people you're going to enroll into
your organization they're going to
become a part of your team or your
company their dreams and their Visions
can fit inside this big one you've got
That's What Makes You magnetic That's
What Makes You compelling that's what
attracts people to you and so anything
art used to say any church Boy Scout
true football team you show me some
that's when it's run by a leader and
leaders have Vision where there is no
vision people perish where there's no
vision your business perishes where
there's no dream whatever Endeavor it is
you're involved in will eventually
perish but if the dream's alive the
dream's big enough
you can accomplish anything because
you'll overcome the adversity the tough
times the difficult times that the
people who ultimately lose won't
overcome really winning
and more about staying power more about
relentlessness more about tenacity more
about Vision more about dreams than it's
ever about skill you show me something
with enough Vision a big enough dream
I'll show you somebody who will
eventually acquire the skills the
talents or the other people necessary to
make that huge dream happen but I seen
all kinds of talented people all kinds
of skilled people that succumb to
adversity some people deceive themselves
into thinking they're further ahead than
they are right yeah constantly I'm you
know they always want to tell you how
well they're doing and they're sort of
deceiving themselves and that deception
leads to lack of activity Drive desire
blah blah blah you and I do the reverse
yeah I just see myself I'm further
behind than I am I know you do this too
because we've talked about it holy I
love deceiving myself I love deceiving
our company I love being I love
deceiving the team because I want us to
feel like we got Malcolm X says it's
great quote he says that which you do
not hate you will eventually tolerate
I'm a big believer and I I gotta almost
despise where I am right now and I do so
I'm I'm the kind of the king of
deception with myself most of you lose
control of your life in the first five
minutes after you wake up I talk about
it in my book and you begin to respond
all day long first thing is this the
hardest thing you will do and the thing
that will change your life almost with
the greatest impact is to not check your
phone for the first 30 minutes you wake
up in the morning I'm telling you that
it might be the biggest game changer it
is the biggest game changer for me it
was so difficult because so what I did
is I I moved it away from where I sleep
but I'm just gonna say to you all you
think that's not a big deal I gotta
check it I'm telling you if you could go
30 minutes if you could start by going
10 minutes to begin your day something
where you do not check that sucker and
react and then what you say about the
Gratitude thing that's profound for me
and it's a breakthrough for me when you
said it I'm always kind of like what are
the big things I'm grateful for God I'm
grateful for my kids you reduce it down
to just something what's the smallest
thing you could be grateful for right I
love that because there's always a small
thing you could be grateful for you know
I'm grateful my I clipped my toenails
yesterday whatever it is right there's
something so I just want to validate how
powerful I think both those simple tools
the simplest things make the biggest
impacts in our lives I want you to write
this down I need to embrace the
suffering you know there's something
powerful that once you just sort of
embrace the fact that in order to
achieve something big you've got to get
rid of these distractions and then the
other layer of it is you're probably
going to have to have some suffering to
get there or some sacrifice to get there
and so once you've embraced and decided
that this suffering this sacrifice
you're making is an indicator of
progress it's an indicator of obsession
suffering and sacrifice and hard work
is an indication of progress towards our
dreams the lack of sacrifice the lack of
suffering in our lives it's removal it's
non-existence also equates to a
non-existence of a great life a
non-existence of a dream happening a big
one anyway and so embrace the fact that
you're gonna have to sacrifice and
suffer to some extent once you've
embraced that it's going to happen it's
almost not that bad it's kind of like
those of you that are fit we already
know and you already know and if you're
not you've sort of accepted that before
you go to the gym and get there you're
gonna have to suffer and we go anyway it
becomes a habit no one goes into a gym
thinking I'm not going to have to
sacrifice or suffer there'll be no
discomfort or no pain but millions of
people go anyway don't they to the gym
on some level they're suffering in the
gym whether it's breathing heavy or
sweating or aches or pains or stress you
know everything in the gym is a
sacrifice and to some extent you're
suffering going through some pain you
know it before you go don't you yet most
of us go all the time yet in life
outside of that one area most of us
are worried about suffering we're afraid
of it when we're suffering and
sacrificing we wonder whether it's worth
it we wonder whether we're supposed to
we wonder whether sacrifice or setbacks
or suffering is a sign it's not our real
dream don't we see at the gym you never
think oh I'm going through some pain and
discomfort this must be a sign I
shouldn't be at the gym you'd never
think that it goes with the territory
everyone knows this build a bicep or a
tricep or a chest or legs you have to
break it down suffer and sacrifice for
it to grow so while it's happening
there's no part of you that says this
isn't right in fact the indication of
the pain and sacrifice and sweat don't
you feel better at the gym you're like
wow I really sacrificed today I really
suffered so in that area we all know to
the extent we suffer in sacrifices to
the extent we grow and your body is a
metaphor for the rest of your life but
the rest of our life every time we sweat
every time we sacrifice every time we
suffer we don't do what we do at the gym
we start saying well wait a minute maybe
I'm not supposed to be doing this maybe
I'm not cut out maybe it's not my
destiny maybe I just can't do it there
are people listening to this who are not
wired
it's okay if you were watching this and
say my goals aren't Financial I'll even
I'll accept that for a second what I
don't accept is when people tell me that
but it's not replaced with another
Obsession that would fulfill them if
it's you know I want to have a million
children get educated or I want to feed
a million people or I want to you know I
want to start a charity that does XYZ
for homeless women all those things will
take money those things don't take money
well or the raising of money right from
someone else and so I I find it I find
it that people either aren't clear on
what their obsessions are or when they
get them they're just some arbitrary
thing they've set low that they think
everybody else would think is a big deal
and so we were just off camera right
before we went live and we're both
saying to each other which is just you
know probably only say to each other we
both really feel like we're behind we
really feel uncomfortable with where we
are because what we want to achieve when
I've done my show the number one thing
that surprised me Omar is in my podcast
and my show is when I interview people
some say it on camera but almost all of
them say it off camera and that is that
honestly this is something people would
be shocked by the mega Achievers that I
have on my show so struggle with what I
would even call borderline depression
this is a secret most people won't tell
you I've seen it on my show as well yeah
and okay so you understand it's
fulfilled or not happy they made the
money but they don't have a momentum I
think there's an element of that right
and I think there's another element that
people that are Mega Achievers have such
gigantic standards and outcomes for
themselves that they're never quite
meeting them and I kind of like that I
kind of think that having some
discomfort with where you are everyone
thinks I I think everyone's fantasy is I
want to get somewhere where I don't want
something anymore listen to me on this I
think a lot of people think if I could
just get somewhere where I no longer
feel uncomfortable where I no longer
want something I don't have when I'm no
longer seeking something what they're
really saying is I'd like to get
somewhere where I no longer will grow
again right I don't want that I always
want to be in a state of discomfort a
state of growth a state of contribution
and so you better be careful that
whatever you set that you're as you're
approximating it as you're getting
closer that the next one's thrown out
there the next one's thrown out there we
spent the better part of the last two
hours both of us we're playing cards
what do you want man what makes you beat
me a card I took literally all his money
tonight as a matter of fact right well
all the money that was on the table but
the point I think I would make to you is
that your obsessions are what you're
going to get so be very careful what you
choose make them big and make sure that
there's something that at least at this
stage of where you are in your current
level of awareness you believe truly
would make you happy truly would make
you fulfilled and be very careful when
you set them and so if that's a million
bucks great like we're both at a point
now where and we don't mean it into
condescending one whatsoever I know that
a million dollars is not a lot of money
in this world right maybe it was a lot
of money in 1940
but it's not anymore people that make
six figures and bless their heart there
are still people walking around that
have deluded themselves into comfort and
thinking I'm successful because I make
six figures six figures is a lot of
money in 1965 man right this is just
2018 2019 when some people will watch
this that's not a lot of money now and
really neither is seven figures in
income anymore right and so it's just a
matter of you getting aware of what your
capacity is and the more you're aware of
how spectacular you're wired the less
you'd shortchange yourself with really
small goals what's something that I
guess Ed's sitting here right now could
go back and tell the young Ed what would
you uh what would you say hey you should
listen to this one wow
um there's a million things
um because I lack so much confidence I
would have first told myself hey man you
deserve to be successful this isn't
relegated to people different than you
yeah I think who are these people that
live in these beach houses and have
these Jets or play on TV in a sport
they're like a different species or
something and as I've got to know them
all from doing my show and just from
living my life to just like you in many
ways they're just human they have the
same emotions the same weaknesses and
whatnot but here's the deal man your
life you're probably never going to
exceed your identity and that your
identity is the thoughts and Concepts
that you believe to hold really to be
true about yourself and you have
multiple identities you have a happiness
one a wealth one a fitness one a
relationship one and you will never
temporarily you could get a better
result than what you believe you're
worth but you'll find a way to cool it
back down your identity is like that
thermostat on the wall it sets the
temperature for your life so if you're a
75 degree or let's just say of wealth
and you live at 75 degrees you might get
it going for a while in business and
you're living at 80 85 degrees but all
of a sudden the thermostat of your life
will kick in unconsciously and you will
find a way to cool it right back down
reverse is true too you start going
broke you can't pay your bills you'll
find a way eventually don't you didn't
starve you didn't get homeless you
heated your life back up to what you
think you're worth yeah and it governs
your life doesn't matter the external
conditions if you have a thermostat in
this room 100 degrees outside it'll
still regulate this room to 75. yeah and
so your identity is a thermostat of your
life and if you don't change the
thoughts Concepts and worth you hold to
be true about yourself all of the other
mechanical things you do you will find a
way most Hall of Fame athletes simply
have a higher identity about their craft
and their career most high performers in
Fitness High performers in a
relationship people in faith their faith
you see someone just lives with great
faith they've got 150 degrees of faith
and so they get that no matter what the
conditions are there's a woman on my
show today Tony who was the mother of a
five four and two-year-old Kayla
stockline her husband was a pastor of a
church
he hung himself last year in their
Church committed suicide and left three
children behind and a loving wife and a
church full of people and on my show she
says that the last year her faith is
only increased and she's closer to God
how in the world is that possible it's
because no matter what the conditions of
her life is she's got this gigantic
Faith identity so my thing I'd go back
and tell me is you better work on this
identity thing all the time bro you
better keep working on it or you will
find a way to cool your life back down
in every area to what you think you're
worth and what you think you deserve one
of the things that you you do and and I
want to remind everybody of something
Lewis's shows called the school of
greatness and it's easy to forget and
maybe no one's told you in a while but
you were born to do something great with
your life and that's easy to forget when
you're you're going I'm in scarcity mode
I need to survive I mean that sounds
great Ed but like you don't understand
I'm I'm unemployed I'm I've got rent
that I'm going to have to start paying
again I understand that and I'm saying
one of the pathways out is you remind
yourself I was born to do something
great in big ways and small ways and
some of the smallest great things you
will ever do in your life
are the most important not the big ones
not the I had Kobe Bryant on my show or
I just spoke to 5 000 people or I made
100 Grand on a sale I'm talking about
the small things that maybe only you and
that other person know about you and I
both just had sometimes our guests
overlap and I love how we approach the
interviews different too we both just
had Nick Voyage on our shows in the last
four five six weeks and he's spoken in I
don't know 75 countries millions of
people he was born with no arms and no
legs he's a friend of both of ours and
it started because a janitor at his
school nudged him a janitor at his
school and said hey I think you'd be a
great speaker a great motivator to
people now that man that helped him that
was a small Act of greatness he maxed
out that day with that person and he
made a difference in the history of
mankind this man spoken to millions of
people saved people from suicide
inspired them for me and you know my
original business was a financial
business well the man who got me
involved in that business was never
financially very successful but I was in
college he said I think you'd be great
and I wasn't interested in Lewis he'd
write me a letter every month I still
believe in you I think you'd be amazing
I think and I get these handwritten
letters every month little acts of
greatness well because of that I've been
able to reach millions and millions of
people you would say well Ed mylett's
done some pretty great things really
well what about Steve Adams who wrote me
all those letters who got me into
entrepreneurship that little what if you
were that person to curate in in Lewis's
words to collaborate who could you
connect what how resourceful could you
be right now in connecting other people
man you start doing that this helpless
feeling goes away this self-confidence
begins to emerge and you ironically
start to create some momentum the most
powerful way and the easiest way to
change your thermostat setting is by
adding people to your circle very close
proximity that live at a higher
temperature in that area than you do for
example in your faith let's just say
you're a 75 degree or in your faith
you've already seen this you can't
possibly begin to regularly associate
with good godly people who pray
regularly who try to live righteously
and they're at 110 120 degrees of of
faith in their life and not have that
proximity heat you up now you won't get
to where they are you'll get to
somewhere between where you are at 75
degrees and they are at 110 over time
you become 100 degree or and you alter
the thermostat setting through
Association same in business if you and
I were to hang around each other every
single day and let's say you were a 75
degree or in business hypothetically and
I don't know that about you but let's
just say you were and I was 150 degree
or and we hung around each other all the
time don't you think through that
Association especially if you had two or
three or four people like me in your
life that just over time you don't even
feel it you're at 80 you're at 85 you're
at 90 you're at 95 and that's where you
are we understand the power of this with
our children because we know at school
the teachers have influence over them
they're mentors but the people that
really have influence over our children
are for their friends because they're
around them all the time and so we know
it sets their temperature this is true
in Fitness if you're a 75 degree of
fitness and every meal every day at the
gym all your associations hypothetically
speaking were with someone who was
shredded and fit the way you wanted to
look at 150 degrees you know over time
you get heated up and so you can't be
with someone every day you can't be with
them all the time but the key is to get
more proximity in the areas that matter
with people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours I am a product you are
listening to me right now because I've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that I want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day I'll give you a
secret one of the reasons I even do my
show is I know that I'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
I'm obsessed with the power of
Association but I don't just associate
see
all personal says yeah you're the five
people you hang around kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time of studying them of observing
them of asking questions of the fact
that you should be altering your
thermostat setting that's when it really
moves it's not just hanging around it's
consciously and intentionally spending
time with people where you allow it to
impact you where you study them where
you really observe them where you're
open to their influence there has to be
a level of trust before you can do that
where you surrender yourself to them but
it's not just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of Association is the main way to do it
we often talk and hear speeches in wfg
myself included TFA about identity and
belief in leadership building and how we
thinking being positive and hard work
and all these intangible things but at
the end of the day it's the tangible
things it's the real things that make
businesses grow or die in our business
it's the ability to get somebody to
produce a result or what I call closing
closing's a nice way of saying or a
harsh way of saying I guess getting
people to do things that are in their
best interest persuading people to say
yes and in our business if you can't
persuade people to say yes you're going
to lose in our business it's yes to the
opportunity and yes to our financial
products and at the end of the day what
our business comes down to is can you
close can you get a check can you get
people to say yes to you to buy a
product from you or to buy our business
from you and then from there it's your
proficiency level your ability to
transfer that skill of closing people
to other people
and if you can't do it you're going to
lose
it's the number one skill it's the
number two skill it's number five skill
it's the number ten skill in our
business I don't care what list you have
it's by far the most important thing and
it's the most important thing multiplied
by ten times other things you could come
up with the ability to get people to say
yes the ability to give a presentation
at the end of it they say yes the
ability to overcome objections when
someone says the basic things in our
business I want to think about it it's
too much money I don't want to be a
salesperson I read something on the
Internet I want to talk to my wife is
this network marketing whatever the
questions are the objections you get
your ability to overcome them and move
to yes if you can't do that you're going
to lose here if you can't train people
to do that you're going to lose here if
your meetings don't train people to do
that people will stop coming to those
meetings
we spend way too much time my
Hallucination is you and your office
spend way too much time on motivating
inspiring speeches instead of teaching
instead of actually getting people to do
our craft to become professionals get
yourself to do it you think about it if
you drew a line in the saying you said
these are all the people in our
organization's history that have gotten
a check or have gotten to SMD
and then on the other side are all the
people who didn't get to SMD or have
never gotten a check what do all the
people who've gotten to check or let's
just say got to SMD which is just a
basic level in our company of
proficiency have gotten to that level
what do they all have in common well not
a lot some of them are smart some of
them are so smart some of them are
Caucasian some of them are Asian black
Hispanic you name it
some of them are tall some of them are
short some of them are men some of them
are women some of them are immigrants
some were born in our country they don't
have a whole lot in common some are
married some are single some are old
some are young what do they have in
common
they can all close they can all get a
yes or at least at one time in their
career they develop the ability to give
a presentation at the end of it somebody
said yes they knew the words they knew
how to say they knew what to say when
someone says well give me some time let
me think about it or is this too much
money or you know I read this or is this
network marketing or you know the basic
stuff right they're not Mysteries only
about eight or ten things people say to
us to object there aren't 800 there's
eight or ten basic ones
and when you can overcome those things
and give a presentation you win we know
they can do this because we wouldn't
have sent them a check without their
ability to do it I'm positive they can
do it at one point because we sent them
a check all these other people over here
who didn't make it didn't get a check or
didn't get to SMD what all them in
common some are smart some aren't so
smart some are black some are white some
are Asian some are Hispanic you get the
point some are tall some are short they
got a they got all that in common too
what do they all for sure have in common
they can't close they can't get a check
that's why we never sent them one it's
why they quit that's why people quit on
you be very clear people quit on you or
you will quit based on your ability or
inability to close when you can close
you're going to do our business and when
you can close and then you can teach
people how to persuade people which is
closing you're really going to build
something significant listen guys it's
it's appreciation and intentional
appreciation so one of the things I'm a
crazy list maker I make lists most
people I know are kind of people who
make lists they're person's blowing your
phone up right now I know I just put it
on airplane mode yeah mine's doing that
too and so I make lists of stuff I got
to do every day why do I do that well it
reminds me I want to do but what I do is
self-confidence is the process of
keeping the promises you make to
yourself you've probably all heard me
say that Lewis say that before but how
do you do that well for me it's the
visual a delivery of it for me so if it
says like Instagram live with Lewis at
10 A.M
um make sure I text Pedro's coolion back
today whatever it is right I've got to
prepare a training I'm going to be doing
in a week I'm doing a Las Vegas TV show
today I got to prep for that and so when
I do something and I check the box I
don't just do it I intentionally go
nailed it nailed it got it got it and I
start banking these deposits in myself
so to speak of another promise Captain
other promise Captain other promise kept
that's something you could be doing
right now I had a little one last night
bro I'm gonna share some with you
Patrick Schwarzenegger and I uh are
pretty good friends I know you know
Patrick too and and I'm watching
Patrick's
um wait didn't I connect you guys
I think you you did connect this day
you're right that's actually right I can
enter into Maria Schreiber because
that's right that's right that's perfect
example of what of collecting oh my gosh
I'm so glad you just said that yes you
did as a matter of fact and Patrick's
this good-looking model actor personal
Improvement guy you know but he's so
good looking he's like a Lewis house
look alike and uh
but on his Instagram he's uh eating ice
cream and eating cake every single day
well he can get away with it whatever
his metabolism is right and I've been
training hard but you may think this is
silly everyone but I have had a little
bit the last two weeks of an ice cream
problem dude I had a whole figure a pint
of ice cream last night I'm with you man
dude I have been plowing ice cream in my
Bible like so bad and I'm like so no
matter what I'm doing to work out I'm
like what is I never sit around and eat
ice cream I mean maybe once a month or
something every damn night I'm on ice
cream and so last night this may seem
like a simple promise I'm not here's how
small life can get when you're in this I
woke up yesterday it was Easter at
Easter with my family I had to drive
back out here to the beach to work today
and I'm like no ice cream tonight no ice
cream and it was on my list of things to
do that day was don't eat ice cream and
I got here last night and I did my work
all day and I do what you do I turn on
Netflix and I'm like all right up on
Ozarks for about an hour oh my gosh now
I finished that the first two days yeah
which is gonna which is going to turn
into eight hours of course right all of
a sudden it's 1am but about midnight I'm
like that ice cream sounds damn good
right now
just a couple bites and then I'm like
well it's 1205 so technically it's the
next day you know you start playing
these games it's not actually that's the
problem anymore you've kept your promise
all right get the promise but the point
is I actually started to walk to the
freezer in the refrigerator you may
think this is stupid everybody and I
went no and I turned back around I got a
bottle of water and I sat and watched
another show and then I went to bed you
may go that's nothing to me that was
another deposit in my self-confidence
inventory I'm keeping promises I make to
myself right so these things may seem
small but at 49 years old this month
the reason I have went from having no
self-esteem no self-confidence
whatsoever
to where I am now which is pretty
confident is that is is that I I started
this process that I know Works which is
Promised cap promise cat promise kept
and these I've made thousands of these
deposits to where when some one thing
hits me that rocks my self-confidence it
doesn't take away from the thousands of
promises I've kept to myself so yeah
just think about that what are the small
things you could be doing I'm a huge
believer in the power of intention and
awareness so when these negative
thoughts creep in whatever they are fear
I'm aware of my own thinking and once
you're aware of a thought it loses its
power to have a feeling over you this is
what most people understand so we're all
going to have those thoughts like oh I'm
losing my dad it's a horrible thing when
you're aware of that negative thought
the feeling loses its power over you one
of the things that I think people need
to start to understand is if you don't
align your thoughts and your feelings
neither one has any power there has to
be a congruency between what you're
thinking and what you're feeling that's
why like for example when people set up
all these goals I'm gonna make a million
dollars or I'm gonna go to the NFL Bell
or I'm going to be happier I'm going to
lose 20 pounds in the moment you're
having that thought if you're feeling
that you can't have it if you're feeling
that's not going to happen your body
which is your unconscious mind actually
at work the feeling overrides the
thought and that goal has no power
that's why I like when you played on my
show I was going to say this to you
afterwards and I did you're talking
about how you'd visualize these things
happening one of the things about
visualization that happens if you put
yourself in the movie of your life you
begin to feel what it feels like to
catch that pass in the end zone so the
thought is simultaneous with the feeling
so if you can begin to visualize what
your goals are and allow yourself to
feel it in the present time and there's
the gift I'll give you
if you could already experience
gratitude for an event or a goal that
has not yet happened but you can
experience the Gratitude so when you
have these visualizations you probably
didn't know you were doing it when you
played but you're visualizing the catch
you're visualizing the celebration
you're already in a gratitude State
about having received the goal you have
now you've aligned and congruence your
feelings with your thoughts now you're a
powerful mfer but what most people do in
their life is they either have the
conscious thoughts overridden by their
like lack I have never done this before
I'm not going to do it I've always been
20 pounds overweight I don't have a
million dollars in the bank and they
write down all these goals that aren't
linked with the feeling people say well
how do I get the feeling you get the
feeling by having gratitude for the
event before it's happened yeah so
gratitude would be my answer I'm trying
to find the thing I'm grateful for
during this event in the present time
the model for me is that I I am about
maxing out in my life
but the model for me is that I've
learned from the mistakes that I've made
and I'm just it sounds as hokey as you
can be I'm trying to get better every
single day every decision I make I just
want to get better because you know what
I can't con I don't compete with other
people I don't compare myself to other
people this is my life right and so the
model for me is this and I just want to
say this to everybody there's probably a
point in your life where you were given
a script of who you were supposed to be
whether it's your parents or your
friends or your spouse and we live too
often in our lives some other person's
script right someone else's script
remember this you're the lead character
in the story of your life and the person
who controls that script is you and your
God and at any point you can decide to
step into a new chapter you can step in
to be a whole new leading character and
too often at the end of a movie you know
at the end of a movie there's the
credits there's like leading character
leading woman but if you watch long
enough eventually you get down there
it's like cab driver number two you know
trucker number three these face they
don't even have names at the end of the
movie right most people live their life
worrying about what cab driver number
two bouncer number three TR instead of
your life is about those leading
characters those five or six or eight
people around you that you love so my
model is I live my own script my model
is I control that script me and God I
can write a new chapter I could right
now you you get off this podcast you can
decide to step out and do a whole new
character maybe not dramatic maybe
you're just a little bit more confident
woman a little stronger a little bit
more dedicated to your focus a little
bit more focused on keeping the promises
you make yourself you just start
stepping into that new place and for me
I write new chapters every year I don't
I'm not interested in reading the past
chapters my past chapters are either or
or stories I've made up in my mind about
how great I was or big failure Stories
We repeat to ourselves I'm about the new
chapter right now not even the future
right now writing that new chapter
that's my model as I I control the
script and I know I control the script
with God's blessing so I was just
visiting about this topic with my kids
and I thought you and I ought to visit
about it too because it applies so
deeply to business and that's the
concept of belief
and how that impacts our performance in
everything
in our lives and what you think about
belief for a second see if you're a good
person and that's really where this
applies is to good people but good
people only let themselves in almost any
Endeavor any activity good people only
take from it that which they believe
they deserve now bad person they'll
always take more than they deserve
because that's what people without
character do but good people and I hope
you consider yourself a good person
they'll only take from something not
they think they deserve Let me Give an
example let's say there was a pizza here
we were going to serve there's 12 people
here there's 12 slices of pizza well you
know how you'd react and any good person
they'd either wait for everybody else to
get their piece or they only take one
slice because they know that the other
people there only would have one left
for them bad person they just take any
time they want to wouldn't they so a
good person will only take from any
scenario that which they think they
deserve that's a good thing it's also a
bad thing because ultimately what it
comes down to in business is is really
this
when it comes to your business life or
becoming affluent saving money getting
financially independent you'll only take
from your life and from your business
that which you think you deserve and so
really almost more important than
strategy is an internal identity it's an
internal belief that says I deserve this
I deserve to be happy I deserve to have
this dream come true I deserve to be
financially independent I deserve to be
in the top 10 in my business I deserve
to be number one or my team deserves to
my family deserves to and once you
believe you deserve something then
you've at least opened the door to walk
into the room of success but prior to
believing you deserve it you can do all
the work all the calls all the mechanics
that the other people do but if you
don't believe you deserve it you're
never going to even walk into the room
and sit at the table to have a chance to
get your piece that the chair at the
table the space at the table is only
reserved for those who believe they
deserve to be sitting there if you're
stuck you're stuck in a story that's
where you're stuck there's a story
you're telling yourself that doesn't
serve you anymore and you have to
evaluate what that story is I'm serious
right now if you say Ed I'm kind of
stuck where I am well what you need to
do is you need to alter your
associations you need something in a
short window of time no question about
it you definitely need to evaluate what
is no longer needed and evaluate the
story you're telling yourself there's
all kinds of stories we tell ourselves
that don't serve us anymore this is
critical maybe it's a story about your
past a story about your parents a story
about a previous relationship a story
about a success you used to have you
keep talking about that doesn't serve
you to get to the next level
if I can be real with you whatever
you've achieved up to this point that
story you keep talking about every
second you spend in that old story about
what you've achieved your degree some
business you had one thing you were real
successful at in the past every time you
live in that story you're stripping time
and focus from the new story what's the
new story you're telling yourself you
can't have a new identity without a new
story what's the old story you keep
repeating maybe it's not a success maybe
it's a failure that you've had it was a
business setback it was the market
turned it was the economy it was someone
who Did You Wrong a relationship that
let you down a business partner who
wasn't consistent a failure you've had a
poor decision you made a mistake you
made
in your life and you're repeating this
story to yourself
simultaneously trying to create a new
identity you can't take that old story
into the new identity one of the great
distractions of chasing our dreams is
this thing that goes off in our head as
we're negotiating the price we're paying
should I keep paying it is it getting
too high is it too much and you'll have
people in your ear it's too big a
sacrifice you're going through too much
and you begin to negotiate it in your
mind it distracts all your focus you
can't be executing and negotiating
simultaneously if you're in your head
negotiating and negotiating and
negotiating you can't execute so
negotiate it now negotiated with me now
what are you willing to pay for me when
I'm after something big as long as it's
legal ethical and moral I'll sacrifice
everything else but I will not sacrifice
anything legal anything unethical or
anything immoral but beyond that I'm
gonna get it and I know that negotiation
comes up front I accept the suffering I
accept the sacrifice I know the
sacrifice is far smaller than the one
I'll pay if I don't do it and I
eliminate distractions and I go freaking
get what I want in my life just like you
can and this needs to be your recipe as
well if you're one of these people who's
still negotiating whether it's worth it
maybe you've got someone in your head
making you question it that is a poverty
and scarcity mentality let me prove it
to you when I didn't have money and I
spent most of my life with none just
like you
what do we do when we go into a store we
don't go get what we want we go get what
we think we can afford and so I spent
the majority of my life flipping price
tags over I didn't buy the shirt I
wanted I buy the one that I could afford
I bought Things based on price not worth
and so I'm sure you know I didn't buy
the car I wanted I bought the car I
could afford so when I was broke and I
had scarcity what do you do when you're
in that position you negotiate price you
flip price tags what's the cost what's
the cost what's the cost what's the cost
not what do you want when I was poor
everywhere I went flipped the price tag
what's your cost what's your cost what's
your cost what's the cause I was
constantly negotiating the price for
everything in my life you do that when
you come from a place of scarcity of
being poor successful people and wealthy
people have a subtle distinction they
don't look at Price they look at worth
is this worth it if you're constantly
looking at the price tag you'll
eventually relent you'll eventually give
in stop negotiating the price it's a
freeing experience to totally commit
when you totally commit to a
relationship to a business to your
Fitness to your faith it's a freeing
powerful it's almost like removing
Kryptonite from your life when you
totally commit can you do that the
people around you always thought it's
costing too much it's costing too much
and you're going maybe it's costing too
much you guys are going no it's worth it
it's not the price it's the worth it's a
subtle distinction in your life that
same scarcity mentality we do and going
after our dreams we want to acquire our
Dream you can't be in price tag mode
what's it cost what's it cost what's it
cost you never get what you want decide
and Advance what it's going to cost and
then decide here's the subtle
distinction successful people don't
negotiate the cost of something they
negotiate whether it's worth it
that's subtle it's very subtle if you're
a person who's always thinking about
what it's costing you in the sacrifice
towards your dream you're always going
to be negotiating it but if you can
decide in advance that the cost is worth
it the negotiation stops and you go
execute what I'm telling you is if you
really want something bad enough it's
worth it it's worth it so start to feed
yourself the worth question over and
over and over again not the cost
question cost is a distraction worth is
a focus mechanism this is so worth it
it's so worth it it's so worth it
focuses you there are six human needs
yep those and they're not wants their
needs there's not eight of them there's
twenty there's six and these needs by
the way at any given time one or two of
them are dominant and the needs are the
need for certainty right in your life
ironically the need for uncertainty yeah
the need for love and connection the
lead the need for significance and
recognition and then growth and
contribution so certainty uncertainty la
loving connections significance growth
contribution those are the 16s and one
of the things we do when we message
people when they don't respond is we
message them with our needs like what
Lewis is saying I need this can you help
me I need a job I need money I need yeah
I need help with this one question the
second thing is to get me to respond to
something when I would say 25 years old
I had a giant need so think through
what's the need of those six that's
dominant for this person on messaging
stay with me everyone on this okay
because when I was 26 years old or 25
years old one of my dominant needs was
significance and recognition just like
yours was right I wanted to be somebody
if you said hey you know I can get you
on my podcast there's a million people
listening to be like whoa significance
right so that would be my need
my need actually if you were to evaluate
Me Now is really contribution yeah
growth so one of the things you could
say is you'd help other people you'd
make a difference think about what my
need might impact a million lives right
20 minute thing with me yeah right you
did it when you asked me to come speak
at school of greatness it was you're you
did it sincerely but it wasn't like hey
Ed there'll be a big crowd it was like
and I really think my family would
respond so well to you right now and I
went I'm in I don't care what it
requires I'm in because I want to serve
I want to make a difference in business
you can become a lot happier person if
you begin to listen less to what people
tell you they're going to do
and focus much more intently on what
they actually do
um it's interesting you have friends all
your life and then you go through an
event like this and you learn who your
real friends are and you've ever been
through a trial in your life or a
difficult time in my case it was a
health issue recently
um it's during those times when people
actually physically step up and show you
that they're your friend that you learn
the most about them it's not someone
telling you I love you or hey buddy you
know care about you it's when you need
them are they there it's what they do
friendship is an action it's an active
thing it's not a state of being and and
I learned a lot this last month or so
about you know some folks frankly
surprised me that reached out and were
there for me and maybe people I didn't
even know would be that don't always
verbalize it but physically they're
friends and then there's other people
that you know you've probably had this
happen to that you go through an event
and uh you're surprised by those that
don't
that weren't there that didn't call that
didn't seem to care and so you learn a
lot by what people do I've learned who
my real friends are
the last few weeks it's been a great
experience I have more friends than I
thought I had which is a good thing but
there are a few folks who I thought were
my friends and maybe they're not and
they certainly didn't act like friends
so but how does it relate to business
well you know you get let down an awful
lot by people by listening to them you
know I've been training people now for
20 something years and well I tell you
people talk a good game people tell you
hey this is my time I'm gonna get five
of these this month or I'm gonna write
10 of those regardless of the business
you're in if you're training or leading
people in any way or you're on a sales
organization or if you're part of our
organization people talk constantly and
if you're if you're not careful you
begin to actually listen to them you
begin to actually believe what people
tell you they're going to do or how they
actually feel all you've got to really
do is watch what they do what you do
speaks so loudly I can't hear a word
you're saying
and you need to embody that yourself in
business because you start to do you
start to act differently based on what
people tell you if someone tells you hey
I'm feeling great I'm going to do big
things maybe you don't do as much
yourself or maybe you don't go get that
next recruit or maybe you don't go get
write that extra sale or fight for that
extra inch because of what other people
have told you they're going to do and
furthermore sometimes even leading
people don't listen so much to what they
took people are going to tell you what
you want to hear I'm going to tell you I
feel great things are good well the
truth is what did they do last month how
much money do they make how much
business do they write because that's
really going to indicate whether they're
going to be with you long term or not I
mean if someone's not making money if
they're not recruiting people if they're
not writing a lot of business they're on
their way out the door not on their way
staying no matter what they tell you I'm
in for life I'm committed you can depend
on me the bottom line is what did they
do last month how much money did they
really make what did they really save
are they actually behind on their bills
are they current on things and so pay
more attention to what people do than
what they say and you will have a much
better barometer of what's really going
on in your business a couple ironic
things about closing and selling that
you may not have ever been told before
but I'm going to tell you people don't
have to believe what you're saying
is that crazy
people do not have to believe what
you're saying in fact too many of you
spend too much time trying to get people
to believe what you're saying and you
come across like a beggar because of it
you seem desperate who's ever trained
you to get people to believe what you're
saying doesn't get influence
there's a subtle difference that the
great ones know and you've probably
never been told this before but I know
it
and persuasion is not about getting
people to believe what you're saying you
ready persuasion is about getting people
to believe
you believe what you're saying that's a
subtle difference brother that's a
subtle difference sister if you start to
think through I need to get people to
believe I believe this not to get them
to believe it people buy things all the
time they don't believe
people buy off things all the time they
don't understand that's okay we want to
educate we want to train but they don't
have to believe everything you're saying
if they have to do that you're going to
look like you're begging all the time
they got to believe you believe it
that's a different intention the most
certain person always influences the set
less certain person when you're
exchanging with a recruiter or a client
they're either going to close you or
you're going to close them
and that certainty certainty is
influence and you can't transfer to me
something that you're not experiencing
for real you have to really believe it
you got to really be a crusader you got
to really understand it when you really
believe something you can transfer that
certainty to me everybody with me on
that say yes this is a huge deal it's a
huge deal but you need to begin to
understand
that persuasion is they believe you
believe what you're saying I love that
most people don't take anything
seriously I love that most people aren't
coachable I love that most people don't
do what I teach or that anybody teaches
I love that that's how certain people
win half y'all haven't written a word
down I've said if you were in my team
I'd slap the hell out of you I don't say
that disrespectfully I say this as a dip
who had a velcro car
I don't say that talking down to you I
say wake up you want to win you want to
be a millionaire you got to quit being
so casual you walk slow you talk slow
you implement things slow you talk a
good game like you're gonna be somebody
like you're gonna make hundreds of
thousands of dollars you can't even
write a note down
you're gonna get your ass kicked in
business dude
business is a sport it's competitive you
got to get focused and get in a hurry
around a dude like me we will smash your
organization we come to play We're for
real what are you cool
I've seen all kinds of cool guys my
whole career cool guys go broke
cool guys have little flashes in the pan
they have a good two or three years
players who Implement strategies that
get focused and intense they win decades
they win multiple championships you win
for two or three years you know many
guys I've known that have made money for
two three four years that are ass broke
now
you got to win year after year after
year
to be a player in business I'm going to
tell you right now either you're going
to control your time or your time's
going to control you either you are
going to dictate the terms of your life
or you're going to be somebody who
reacts and responds throughout their
life this device right here can both
speed up time in your life or it can
slow it down it's not always a speed
tool so one of the tips that I've
covered before but not enough people
Implement that I promise you is a
quality of maxed out performers that
relates to their time is they control it
they do not react and respond they
dictate the terms of their life most of
the time and that means this when you
wake up in the morning the greatest
thing you could do for yourself is not
touch or look at this device for 30
minutes to an hour after Awakening so
that when you wake up you take control
of your time you control the time you
control the beginning of the day you get
clear you meditate you pray you stretch
you think you go through a gratitude
exercise you control the first 30
minutes of your day it sets a tone that
I'm in charge of my time not what enters
this if the first thing you do is grab
this this now dictates the term of your
day this controls my day what hits this
what email what text what call hits this
what Instagram posts hit this this
controls me it controls my time but if
you can stay away from it for the first
30 minutes to an hour you send a message
to your brain to yourself that you
control time that this day is on your
terms and again you stack up a day a
week a month a year five years of a
lifetime of you controlling and
dictating the terms of your life there's
also this misconception from people that
you are certain things meaning some
people have this misconception that I am
what I possess
in other words I am my possessions and
so they link their self-confidence to
their possessions and so they're
constantly trying to acquire more and
more possessions thinking that's where
they get their self-confidence from
that's how they're defined as a person I
am my possessions couldn't be further
from the truth it's a hollow way to try
to gain self-confidence by possessing
things nothing wrong with going for
material possessions I have all kinds of
them but I don't link my confidence to
those possessions nor am I deluded into
thinking if I could just possess more
things then I'll feel better about
myself so this is a mistake there's a
flawed thought number one flawed thought
I am my possessions second flawed
thought I am my accomplishments in other
words my self-confidence is only linked
to what I'll accomplish so because I
haven't accomplished certain things I
know that certain title that certain
award that certain recognition I don't
believe in myself I'm riddled with
self-doubt I'm defined by my
accomplishments the difficult thing
about that is now all your your life
you're gonna have to accomplish more and
more and more in order to feel
self-confident and eliminate self-doubt
you are not your accomplishments you are
not your possessions you are you you are
perfect you are beautiful you were born
to do something great with your life if
you're a person of Faith like me you
believe God Made You In His Image and
likeness and wants you to do something
great with your life not that you are
your possessions not that you are your
accomplishments and this is the the
social media Insidious influence it has
in our lives people think I don't feel
good about myself I've got this
self-doubt the gateway to me feeling
more self-confidence is if I could
possess more things or if I could
accomplish more things yes having nice
things will make you feel better about
yourself yes accomplishing things
certainly is a reinforcement for
self-confidence but it's not the pathway
to getting it the pathway to getting it
is doing something great with your life
where you keep the promises you make to
yourself and acknowledge this self-doubt
this self thought this negative talk
isn't even mind it was given to me when
it was impossible for me to defend
myself as a child and maybe it even
happened in adolescence and probably
some of those incidences have happened
for you as an adult and these ones as an
adult are like that thing I said earlier
oh it's another time I reinforced the
table I'm not good enough I'm not smart
enough I'm not prepared enough I'm not
the right race I'm not the right gender
I don't come from the right kind of
family I don't have the right education
and we find these references as adults
to reinforce these self-doubting beliefs
we were given by somebody else as a
child flawed belief is that you are your
possessions you are your accomplishments
third flawed belief I am what other
people say I am
wrong you are not what other people say
you are good or bad I see too many
people that if someone says something
negative about them they believe that's
who they are this is the flawed third
belief I am my possessions I am my
accomplishments and you know what or I
am what other people say I am let me be
clear with you you are not what other
people tell you you are they it wasn't
true when you were 18 months old five
years old or 55 years old you are not
what other people say you are so stop
letting that dictate your
self-confidence or fill you with
self-doubt and for the record you are
also not the good things people tell you
you are all the time don't live for
likes don't live for comments on your
social media don't don't do things in
your life just to solicit someone saying
something great about you it's a cheap
shallow Hollow way to try to gain
self-esteem and self-confidence it's
fleeting it's short term and it's needy
in fact the fact that it is a necessity
for you to get liked to get people to
say good things to get comments on your
social media or to do so in your
presence indicates a lack of self-esteem
and self-confidence because we know
self-confidence is an internal game
where we keep the promises we make to
ourselves the fourth type of flawed
thinking is I am what I look like
in other words if I don't look a certain
way like what the magazine says I should
or social media says I should if I don't
look like these people I shouldn't have
self-confidence and that's ridiculous I
can tell you straightforwardly you're
beautiful as you are especially the
ladies listening to this or watching
this the world is constantly trying to
get you to believe you're not enough you
don't look right you should lose this
weight you should gain this this should
be smaller that should be bigger
whatever it might be they're constantly
messaging women you're not enough you're
not enough you're not enough you are
what you look like and this is true for
men as well let me tell you
straightforward that you are not what
you look like you are your soul you are
your spirit you are your gifts you are
the contributions you make you are your
intentions I've made a mistake in my
life and that is it's it's contrary to
what I teach I've not been great in my
life at being present I've not been
great at it I think a lot of achievers
struggle with this and I go in and out
of this mode where if I was in the was
it the pool yesterday with my kids
and I'm looking at them and man Max is
going to college this year my daughter's
like a young woman now you know and I
wish when they were a little younger
that those moments when we were in the
pool when they were younger I was just
with them I'm not thinking about work
and thinking about protecting them and
thinking about saving for college and
being in the moment and enjoying now
right like really enjoying now and the
moments I'm the most effective the most
Blissful the most joyful spreading it is
what I'm the most present and I've
always struggled with that because I'm
always dreaming about the future and
wanting to achieve in the future the
best me is the one when you're just me
and you were in the backyard you know
and it's just me and you Louis and and
so for me I go back to the 30 year old
and I'd say I want you to achieve I want
you to win please enjoy this moment
please be present right now the 40 year
old Lewis with this beautiful
relationship you're in now and all the
achievement don't miss now for what the
possibilities are in the future like
enjoy now if this moment right now with
the corona crisis teaches us all
anything it's like all we really have is
right now and the more you project into
the future you know I said in my post
today on Instagram I said or on all
social media I said you know worrying
doesn't solve today's problems it takes
away today's piece and and and and I so
I that's most of my posts are lessons
for me so that would be my lesson at 30
40 and 50 is be more present be you
can't love yourself if you're not being
yourself just be you just be present so
I think I had a lot of beat up I mean
emotional mental psychological beat up I
was like
beating myself to death psychologically
for decades of my life and one thing
brother because I know you've written so
eloquently about this for everybody that
started with you acknowledging and
realizing a pattern yeah so we have
these patterns of behavior right and so
when you acknowledge a pattern you have
that does not serve you it loses a lot
of its power over you just by you seeing
it being aware of it like for example in
business for me
usually when I'm doing well there's this
really intense version of me I always
like that guy but man does he produce a
lot of results he gets paid
and and I'm back sort of in the hunt in
a lot of my business in such a way and
that guy's sort of re-emerging and I've
asked my and there's this part of all of
us that think
this that's why I'm successful so if I
took this intensity away or I took this
self-doubt away or I took this anxiety
away I'll lose my mechanism to achieve
we all think this it's complete BS
or not to interrupt you but yeah or if I
take this away I'll lose the opportunity
for girls to want me or have sex with
women or to lose the weight or to do
this if I take this away right we think
that's part of our secret recipe when in
fact brother and you've realized this
too you're in a more Blissful
relationship now that you were
succeeding in spite of those patterns
not because of them what they are is
they become part of your identity so you
think that's why they produce these
results but you're winning instead of
them in spite of them and so for me just
when they rear their head I'm like I'm
doing that stupid pattern again here I
go again and it loses some of its power
over me and so you're you're a million
percent right and that's why I I feel so
such optimism about my life is because I
know I kind of know me so I know when
I'm doing that guy here he goes the
worry in me here he goes the
overreacting me you're doing it again
and it's almost like a clown show when I
do it instead of me going well that's
why I win I mean hey you may not like
that guy but man he became a millionaire
look at my view look at my house look at
this yeah and then you use these
external things to validate your own
negative pattern for me it's come down
to maxing out and what maxing out means
is you do one more at least than you
think you're capable of so when you're
done whatever you're doing whether it's
at the gym or phone calls or meetings or
in sports one more shot one more throw
one more swing of the golf club or the
baseball bat the separator is for the
winners they do one more I'm addicted to
one more and so I want your Mantra going
forward to be one more what does that
look like if we're working out that
means when we're in the gym and we say
I'm gonna do five sets of ten I'm crazy
like I'm a psycho because I want to win
I want to be somebody I want to separate
I want to compete
and the way I do that isn't with my
giftedness because I wasn't born with a
bunch of gifts and I think gifts are
crap I think for the most part gifted
people struggle in life because things
come easy to them I like that things
haven't come easy for me in my life I
like to have natural talents in every
area and maybe you like that about you
too maybe you've looked at yourself all
your life and thought man I don't have
that natural beauty or that natural
Talent or this gift for creativity or
intellect or humor I don't have any of
those things but what I got is I will
outwork you and so at the gym one of the
things I focus on they say it's five
sets of ten when I'm at ten I go one
more bam 11. if I'm running on the
treadmill and it's a 45 minute run I
never finish at 45 I always go one more
minute 46. if I'm at the office and I'm
supposed to make 25 phone calls that day
when I'm at the end of the day I always
do one more if I've got meetings I
always do one more my mantra for three
decades in business has been one more
why because we get out of life what we
think we deserve and I'm the kind of guy
that I know when you do 45 minutes on
the treadmill and I do 46 I deserve to
be fitter I know that when I'm lifting
weights and I watch you do five sets of
Tenon every single time I do one more
when it's a set of five I do six when
it's a set of eight I do nine when it's
45 on the treadmill I do 46. when it's
supposed to be 20 phone calls I make 21.
when it's supposed to be an eight hour
work day I work nine whatever it is I
always do one more and what that does is
it makes me eventually think I'm doing
things other people aren't willing to do
so I should get things other people
aren't going to get you are you are one
decision
in your life
and you have to
exaction one new decision away from
shifting your life from where it is
right now to a totally different place
so what's the decision you already know
I could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave
I don't know what it is but I know
there's a decision that you need to make
to take you to the next level just like
I know that's true for me because
decisions shape our destiny when they're
backed up by some massive ass action
okay but you can't take the action if
you don't decide everyone say yes people
avoid being desperate think of the fact
they come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially the relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those of you that are achieving one
of the reasons the achievement is slowed
down is you've allowed yourself to feel
less desperate when you were broke and
starting your business or when you were
brand new in your relationship and you
were desperate to get her to love you or
desperate to get him to love you you
took massive big action how many of you
are moms in the room raise your hand you
moms if you woke up tomorrow morning and
your baby wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no
Big Time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take Massive
Action you'd search the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you you wouldn't
would you have to have the perfect plan
to go find your baby that's missing you
wouldn't need any of that because you
were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all sin and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and I
want you to get desperate to make that
decision why because our obsessions
become our possessions which you obsess
about most regularly you will eventually
possess in your life the challenge for
most people sisters and brothers is that
we obsess on the things we're fearful of
what we don't have what we're worried
about and then we end up possessing
those things over and over again rather
than programming ourselves to become
obsessed with what we want what our
dreams are what we believe we deserve
when we come obsessed about those things
long term we end up possessing those
things can I get an amen for that yes
yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our Lives because
those things happen naturally without
thought the external results of our life
in order to replace ourselves with the
next best version requires an intention
requires Obsession requires desperation
everyone with me on that say yes so it's
not unnatural to change your friends
that think you're crazy to have started
your business or come to a seminar or
spend money you don't have they're The
Crazy Ones it's unnatural to be the same
person you are right now next year for
all of you in here the 35 year old you
should be gone next year forever and
there should be a brand new better 36
year old you 20 year olds there should
be a better 21 year old next year you
should constantly be replacing yourself
just like your bones do just like your
lungs do just like your cells do it's
natural to be replacing ourselves but
we're around people who aren't so we
think it's natural not to if you want
another amazing Ed mylett clip check it
out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there